while there have been plenty of
tantalizing details dropped about xiang
chi and the legend of the ten rings we
haven't gotten a chance to see how the
film will look until now a newly
released teaser offers plenty of clues
for what fans can expect
here's what you may have missed the
xiangchi teaser trailer makes it clear
from the get-go that the character
played by orkwafina
is a very important one she's seen at
the hotel slash resort that shangqi
works at
grabbing drinks and singing karaoke with
him and later crashing a bus through san
francisco
as shangqi fights some bad guys even if
marvel told us nothing official about
torquafina's shang chi character
we're given enough to infer what her
role in the film is
she shang chi's close pal who knows
absolutely nothing about his
past life working as an assassin in
training under the ten rings
thankfully both marvel and aquafina have
actually told us a bit about the
character
her name is katie and dorquefina can't
wait for fans to meet her
the actress told stylecaster in a
december 2020 interview
there's a little bit of me in every
character i play which is a good and
bad thing i do feel like i can relate to
her she is thrust into a world where she
doesn't really know what to do
at the same time she's discovering
things about herself
aquafina also admitted that she can't
say much about the role
which could suggest there might be more
to katie than meets the eye
or it may be that aquafina is simply
abiding by marvel's zero tolerance
policy on spoilers regardless of whether
kz is the everyday friend to balance out
chiang chi's larger than life superhero
adventures
or if she has some secrets of her own
having a super talented star like
corkina in your movie
basically guarantees a good time we make
a good team
early on in the film's teaser trailer
xiangchi and katie are seen at a karaoke
bar
it's a sweet moment to establish their
friendship but it actually holds more
meaning than you might realize
if you look at the screen behind
shanghai and katie you'll see that it
reads
over sideways and under these are lyrics
from a disney classic
a whole new world the defining tune from
1992's aladdin
since the walt disney company owns
marvel studios and all its properties
xiangxi and katie singing a whole new
world makes for a fun little nod to the
huge universe
under mickey mouse control plus xiangxi
star or kwafina also recently voiced the
dragon sisu
in walt disney animation studios raya
and the last dragon
additionally aladdin is one of the very
few non-white stories from the disney
renaissance era of animation
so the reference to it in the shanghai
teaser trailer
highlights the importance of diverse
narratives in terms of its connection to
xiang chi and the legend of the ten
rings
a whole new world ties into the movie's
theme of being stuck between two
different worlds
just as the titular aladdin does in his
own film xiang chi has two lives as a
ten rings trained assassin
and as a normal guy working at a hotel
in california
and the two are going to collide in
major ways those who know him from one
life will be brought into the whole new
world of the other
and we can't wait to see how it plays
out one of iron man 3's better plot
twist reveals that the mandarin the
supposed leader of the 10 rings
terrorist organization
is actually trevor slattery an
out-of-work actor that aim higher to
pretend the accidental
extremist explosions were terrorist
attacks the trailer for xiang chi and
the legend of the ten rings
shows that there is in fact a real mcu
mandarin
but he isn't as comic readers remember
him in the comics
xiangxi has two claims to fame he's a
master martial artist
and he's the son of the immortal chinese
sorcerer zhangju
who was originally the character fu
manchu however in the mcu
xiang chi is the son of wenwoo the man
who narrates the movie's trailer
marvel no longer has the rights to fu
manchu more importantly the xiang chi
teaser trailer implies that wen wu is
actually the mandarin
who appears in front of a wall with a
circle of 10 rings on it at the one
minute mark
based on what's shown in the teaser
trailer xiang qi and the legend of the
ten rings mandarin appears to be a
combination of the original comic
incarnation
who uses 10 rings of power and zheng zhu
poor trevor was last seen getting
kidnapped by a henchman of the real
mandarin in the mcu shorts
all hail the king could we possibly see
the fake mandarin come face to face with
the real one in shanghai
it's complicated hey it's complicated
nice
it's complicated i'm complicated at
several points on the xiangchi teaser
trailer there's a man wearing a black
white and red mask
the footage doesn't reveal the man's
identity but some quick intellect
sleuthing tells us that he's
a death dealer aka li ching lin clearly
one of the adversaries xiang chi will
take on during the film
in the marvel comics lee is a double
agent of fu manchus
pretending to work undercover in his
organization for mi6
after lee is deemed too dangerous the
director of mi6 tasks xiang chi
for taking out the agent chang chi
defeats lee in combat but the latter is
able to get away
fu manchu eventually gives lee the
nickname the death dealer
xiang chi and the death dealer go on to
face off against one another
several times on the comics the comic
history between the enemies isn't
lengthy
so we expect to see an expansion on the
pair to brief story in chiang chi
since most of the death dealer's story
in the comics revolves around his
relationship with fu manchu
it's likely his backstory will be
lightly changed to swap through manchu
for the mandarin
in the teaser trailer the death dealer
is training xiangxi while he's a young
boy
whipping him on his back as he tries to
perfect him it appears as if the death
dealer is working with xiang chi at the
direction of his father the mandarin
which would make the death dealer a
member of the terrorist organization the
10 rings
it also looks like the death dealer
student will eventually become the
master
as the pair come to blows twice in the
trailer with one fight sequence
involving some bucky barn's ask and
knife skills
there are plenty of characters who make
an impression in the new shanghai and
the legend of the ten rings teaser
trailer
but one in particular is incredibly
memorable despite only appearing a
handful of times
a couple times in the trailer a dude
with a literal sword for a hand
shows up to make trouble for shangqi if
you're wondering who this sharp fellow
is
he's none other than the mcu version of
marvel comics villain razor fist
razor fist made his debut in 1981's
master of kung fu series
quickly establishing himself as a thorn
in the side of xiangxi
and his allies in the comics three
different men have gone by the name
razor fist
and they all happen to be brothers whose
hands get cut off and replaced with
swords
douglas scott william scott and william
young
simply put this is not a family
tradition that anyone should try to
emulate
in any event all three of these razor
fists are master martial artists
and have all pestered xiangxi at one
time or another
or sometimes at the same time what a
family in the film razorfist is going to
be played by romanian boxer turned actor
florian muntiano
who previously appeared as victor drago
in creed 2
and is set to play krieg in the upcoming
borderlands film
continuing the trend of character
reveals without any explicit details
the teaser trailer also gives us a first
look at xiangxi's sister
xiaolink played by menger zhang
interestingly enough
charlene isn't a marvel comics character
she appears to be inspired by shang
chi's many sisters and half sisters
from his long history in the pages of
marvel comics and we're guessing one of
the biggest inspirations for charlene
comes from the comic book character esme
the daughter of zheng zhu
who is also shang chi's father in the
marvel comics esme is the champion of
the house of the deadly dagger
and goes by the alias sister dagger she
eventually becomes a commander of the
five weapons society
to which xiangxi is a rightful heir
according to leaks for the marvel
legends toys for shanghai and the legend
of the ten rings
shaleen and chang chi are estranged but
that changes when chongqi asks his
sister for help in defeating the ten
rings
the toy description also notes that
charlene has to decide whether to stay
reclusive
or join her brother in his quest from
her appearance in the teaser trailer
where she's seen standing like she's
prepping for battle
it looks like she chooses the latter
even though
xiang chi is a force to be reckoned with
in the main marvel comics universe
he's an unknown within the mcu xiang chi
and the legend of the 10 rings
will mark his movie debut and many
viewers might not know what he's capable
of
the teaser trailer demonstrates that
xiangxi is a master fighter
but at one minute seven he passes his
hand through water
that seemingly defies gravity and time
you probably wonder how he's doing this
and the answer is more than likely
he isn't in the comics xiangxi is a son
of a sorcerer but he didn't inherit any
of his father's magic
he's a straight-up martial artist
trained to surpass the peak of human
performance
skilled in both freehand and armed
combat xiang chi
is essentially the type of character
bruce lee liked to portray in his movies
he could probably out fight someone like
spider-man or daredevil
but he probably wouldn't stand a chance
against the hulk or thor
this knowledge brings us back to the
slow water scene in the shanghai and the
legend of the ten rings teaser trailer
given changchi's shock in that
particular moment odds are that event is
the result of the mandarin's ten rings
depicted as armbands in the film
in the comics a race of alien dragons
forged the rings which possess a variety
of powers including a pocket darkness
shroud
and mata rearrangement granted we don't
know if these origins or abilities will
be directly transferred from comic pages
to the big screen
but the teaser shows young bands glowing
so they clearly aren't just for
decoration
with any luck changsi will add the
armbands borderline supernatural powers
to his own pre to natural abilities
before the movie's end
an exciting chase sequence that involves
a bus and a dump truck
features prominently at the end of the
shanghai teaser trailer
and we see where this chase takes place
when san francisco's famous gira delhi
square comes in the picture
as countless movies readily attest the
streets of san francisco are a prime
location for a cool car chase
and since ghirardelli square is full of
all sorts of nice platforms and
fountains
one couldn't complain to the action
transition from vehicular mayhem
to an elaborate fight scene on the
square itself incidentally the fact that
a part of xiangxi and the legend of the
ten rings takes place in san francisco
raises a possibility for a potentially
massive cameo
or a tiny one as the case may be after
all scott and man lang
and hope the wasp of van dyne are both
active in the area
and it's highly unlikely that they'd
ignore a giant car chase with
supernatural kung fu
overtones on their turf could change
give fans a dose of quantum mania before
the size shifting heroes return in their
upcoming third movie
anything's possible zhang ji and the
legend of the 10 rings are set for a
september 3rd debut
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one